foreign
[Music]
I am a faculty investigator at the
Hudson Alpha Institute for biotechnology
located in Huntsville Alabama we're a
non-profit genetics and genomics
research center and we're all dedicated
to the the use of uh genetic and genomic
Technologies to improve Human Health and
Welfare and today I'm excited to talk to
you about some of the work we've been
doing recently uh focused on long-reach
genome sequencing for the the diagnosis
of neurodevelopmental disorders
so just to set the stage in terms of the
kinds of phenotypes we're talking about
here uh neurodevelopmental disorders are
kind of an umbrella term that captures
uh it's approximately one to three
percent of children that are born with
symptoms including things like
intellectual disabilities developmental
delays dysmorphic features autism
seizures and other kinds of problems
related to growth and development
uh that can lead to a whole range of
different uh
cognitive and physical uh challenges
and the vast majority of these are at
least a very large fraction of these uh
have genetic causes uh in fact tend to
be rare genetic causes and because
they're a rare genetic causes in order
to find a correct diagnosis you have to
find those rare genetic causes and so an
accurate diagnosis is in terms really
essential to give families the best
possible counseling about what caused
the problem what what to expect in the
future to of course to treat the effect
of children in the most effective way in
terms of whether that's
Pharmaceuticals or educational or
counseling or social uh connection to
other families that sort of thing so and
of course in the Long Long Haul we
really need to understand root genetic
causes in terms of developing the most
effective treatments doing research on
Infected treatments in the future so
that's really the focus here today is on
the discovery of these rare genetic
factors that can underlie
neurodevelopmental conditions in kids
so we've been doing this for for quite a
long time at this point so uh Hudson off
in general and so we've partnered with
clinics uh and hospitals throughout
especially uh Alabama but also really
across the southeast uh to identify
children that had an unexplained
neurodevelopmental Disorder so our
primary partners are our first partner
with backless Martina Bevan a really
wonderful UAB Affiliated neurologist
that performs most of our work in in
Huntsville that was part of a project
called We're part of a nhgri program
called Caesar
we work with a state Alabama state
agency that helps children's a family of
children with special needs help CRS and
they have clinics all across Alabama
that we can recruit through
we currently have a grant as part of a
Caesar renewal called South seek where
we're sequencing babies that are in a
neonatal Intensive Care Unit uh at five
different hospitals across the South
that are indicated here and essentially
we're we're looking for babies that have
signs of a rare genetic condition that's
that's the
explanation for why they're in the
hospital
uh we've worked with something called
the Alabama genomic Health Initiative or
aghi this is a state-funded
collaboration between UAB and Hudson
Alpha that has a variety of genomic
medicine
goals including rare disease diagnosis
uh in our sort of standard uh uh
pipeline or process historically at
least has been a Lumina genome
sequencing so this is a standard
generate short reads uh to about 30X
mean coverage via Illumina uh and then
perform variant interpretation and
assessment we started before the the
acmg the American College of medical
genetic standards were developed but we
now adopt the those ACC standards for uh
for waiting evidence and and assigning
terms uh in terms of what the the
likelihood of a variant being causally
connected to a phenotype that we're
interested in
so to summarize a whole bunch of work
over these past uh close to 10 years
we've been doing this so we've sequenced
close to 1400 Pro bands it's probably a
little bit over that today we often do
trio sequencing so that's why it's a
little over uh 2 800 total individuals
because that includes in many cases we
sequence parents
and you can see a a breakdown here this
pie chart that shows the breakdown of of
pathogenic likely pathogenic vus and
then no returnables
uh so the uh there are about 370 Pro
bands so a little over quarter have a
path or likely path and we sort of tend
to lump those together because those are
often the kinds of the the variants that
have the kind of consonants attached to
them that leads to allowing a clinician
to make a make an actual diagnosis
so we have a number of of genes that we
see over and over again things like
survey syndrome and red syndrome which
are among the more common rare diseases
a little bit of a weird way to say that
but
more uh
200 over 200 distinct scenes so these
are individually quite rare conditions
even though they add up to a
collectively uh quite common set of
conditions so you can see that the
breakdown here for most of these and
slight majority are de novo but of
course we also see recessive and
dominant and occasional x-linked uh
barriers we also find lots of the USS so
over 200 up to this point and these are
mostly de Noble variants and conserved
genes that we just don't understand and
I'm not going to talk about that today
but that's a major focus of what we do
is try to try to understand which of
those vuses are likely to turn into uh
because we have seen many examples but
of course you have to do the work to
prove that any individual of the US is
actually pathogenic
but today what I really want to focus on
is the fact that uh we fail frankly in
in most of the children that we sequence
we just don't find anything and that's
really the focus here today is on
understanding uh how we can do a better
job at diagnosing children in this
currently undiagnosed bucket
and so the the big picture and this fits
into a broader set of research from lots
of groups is that there are many
patients that have severe early onset
symptoms that really suggest a large
effect genetic variant based upon just
the nature of their presentation there
is also of course a large effort to look
at mendelian disease more broadly so
this isn't just neurodevelopmental
disorders there's lots of conditions
that are either suspected to be
mendelian or in fact known to be
mandelion via linkage or other kinds of
family assessments and even in those
families you often fail to find a causal
variant and so the bottom line is that
we believe there are lots of Highly
penetrant variants out there that we're
just not seeing and as a result of that
that if we can do a better job at
finding variants and and finding those
causal variants that are underlying
these mendelian disorders that this
could unlock a whole bunch of both
research discoveries that are important
and also obviously clinically relevant
uh translationally important findings
so today I want to talk about our
efforts to do this with with long read
genome sequencing so this project I'll
talk about is the collaboration with
Jane grimwood and Jeremy smutz who are
uh colleagues faculty members here at
Hudson Alpha and for a long time they
have been the or they currently are and
have been for a long time directors of
the what's called The genome sequencing
Center genome sequencing Center at
Hudson Alpha they're primarily funded by
the department of energy but other
sources as well it may have done loads
of work on De novo Assemblies of plant
genomes so they often joke that human
genomes are actually quite simple
compared to a lot of the plants that
they've looked at and so basically their
uh their focus has been on building
these reference maps for these
complicated large genomes and as part of
that they have lots of expertise in
infrastructure for sequencing and
assembly obviously but that includes
being beta testers for the a platform
from Pacific bioscience is called
circular consensus sequencing or hi-fi
uh so they had this installed about two
years ago and just to give you a sense
for how Hi-Fi reads work they uh you
start with large molecules obviously
we're trying to get long reads so you
try to get molecules that are 10 20 30
50 kilobases long they uh this process
includes ligating these adapters that
end up circularizing those molecules and
that's really the the key to making this
work is that Circle structure so that
when you uh when the the when the
molecules get sequenced the polymerase
can actually Loop over and over again
over the same fragment
and what this does is it overcomes the
traditional downside to Long reads which
was low accuracy at the base pair level
so you you would often get you know
something like 15 20 25 error rate at
any given base call but when you
sequence the same base over and over
again those error rates move out and the
result is that you get reads that are
both long so you can get reads that are
10 20 30 50 kilobases long but they're
accurate at the base pair level and in
fact you can see uh reads that that are
essentially at alumina base hair
accuracy so greater than 99 base care
accuracies as a result of this redundant
sequencing approach and I say this
figure is from a paper published by Pac
bio on the technology
and so we decided to work with Jane and
Jeremy and we worked with them to
generate CCS uh genome data on six Trio
six children and their parents that we
had previously worked with and yet still
were had an unexplained neurodevel
tunnel disorder you can see here just a
breakdown a very high level overview of
uh of the children that we looked at
here these symptoms that you're looking
at here are are fairly typical Caesars
dysmorphia intellectual disabilities
like I mentioned before
you can see all of these children ahead
and I'm just giving you a small snippet
here of the previous testing that had
been done so all I had microarrays we
had done either genomes or exomes on all
of these children and this is not to
describe all the different other kinds
of chemicals and any kinds of testing
that have been done and what we went
ahead and generated was we aimed for
about 30X coverage on the pro bands and
then we generated lower for the sake of
efficiency we we generated lower but
still fairly decent coverage so
something like 15 to 20x on average for
the the parents but the idea being that
all the variants that we call in the in
the child that we could use the lower or
you know medium coverage data from the
parents to determine whether those
alleles have been inherited or not
so to give a quick sort of process
overview we uh took a number I mean this
really was a long time uh to develop
sort of pipelines and procedures that
worked we performed a set of analyzes
where we took the reads and just aligned
them to hd38 so treated them much the
same way that you would treat Illumina
reeds and then perform variant calling
via a deep bearing here we tried a
number of different algorithms We
performed structural variant calling
using again a variety of approaches but
primarily we focused on this PBM
alignment and pbsv collar but I'll talk
about other things as well
ultimately we called about 7 million uh
sort of standard variants so it's smbs
and indels seven million per Trio so
reasonably close to expectation and
really a really exciting result here is
that there's only about 89 high quality
de novo smbs and indels for Pro Band and
just to put that in perspective
um the the biological expectation is
something on the order of something like
70s uh a given child is on average has
about 70 de novo smbs or indels or
somewhere in that vicinity so that's
that's reasonably close to what the
expectation is and what but
unfortunately what you often see in um
in standard approaches is is several
holes higher than that you often see
multiple hundreds of De Noble calls for
various technical reasons when you look
at Short read data so this was an
encouraging sign that we were getting
pretty high quality uh de novo calls
which are obviously very important to uh
neurodevelopmental conditions
we also generated de novo assemblies and
this is something that is really
uniquely powered by having long read
data that you just can't do very well
with short reads we used an approach
called Hi-Fi ASM and what's Missy about
Hi-Fi ASM is that this is not in a trio
aware fashion so you can take the the
information from each Pro Band and use
the parental genotypes to actually phase
to build and phase content so that you
can look at you can separate out the
maternal chromosomes from the paternal
chromosomes and assemble them separately
in each Pro Band
and just to give a rough overview of
what that looks like it's really
remarkable how good the assemblies can
be so this is uh from the Hi-Fi ASM
assemblies where we're looking at within
each so each of the six Pro bands here
uh uh articulated on the x-axis and what
we're able to do is assign as I
mentioned maternal and paternal
chromosomes and so essentially treat
their assembly separately and you can
see we're getting n50s here so these are
you know the length of contigs in which
50 of all the bases are assembled into
uh over 12 megabases for all cases again
both both maternally and certainly
inherited chromosomes and in some cases
we're getting uh n50s in the 35 uh plus
megabase range so this is effectively
chromosome arm scale pieces that we're
getting uh just from the ccs and HiFi
ASM approach so really uh exciting data
at that high scale contiguity level
well as I mentioned my focus our focus
is really on uh finding rare variance
driving mendelian disease so I want to
walk through a couple of stories that we
found within these families that we
looked at the first is uh we found this
interesting set of reads uh I'll talk
about the second here a gene called
cdkl5 so you can see on the bottom this
is a a map of an annotation of cdklx5
this is Exon three we're looking at a
particular so you're looking at uh
something like 500 or so basis here and
what this graph is showing is from an
igv so this is a standard viewer to look
at alignment of reads to the reference
where uh we have reads from Mom on the
bottom and dad in the middle and we're
not showing all of their reads in this
case we're just truncating that but
we're showing you mostly reads from the
program in this case and in in an ITV
image the gray areas are stretches of
individual Reeds that match to the
reference and the multi-colored areas so
the red and green and blue are bases in
those Reeds that don't match to the
reference and so you can see here uh in
and around this Exon 3 of cdkl5 we have
mom and dad looked normal right so we
have uh like I'm not showing you all the
reads but they they all look like that
gray stretch solid across the entire uh
region here but you can see in the Pro
Band while we do have uh reefs that
appear to be normal across the entire
region you also have these two sets of
breeds and I uh that have these break
points in them where they transition
from matching the reference to having a
whole bunch of mismatches and so they're
they had stresses were to be indicative
of something different happening in the
program and you can see we've marked
with the black triangles there the break
points inside these reads of where this
transition occurs from normal read to uh
to mismatched uh non-aligning read and
of course so this suggests that there's
something going on here but uh it
doesn't really tell you what the nature
of the variant is and but this is the
one of the power of looking at an
assembly so here I'm showing you uh one
way to visualize how assemblies compare
to each other which is a Dot Plot and
basically what this is showing here is
uh comparisons of uh the assembled
contig from the Pro Band against the
assembled contig from the reference from
ac38 and in reasons where they're the
same you get and you can see that the
main diagonal here uh is are these these
stretches where reference the reference
contig and the program contig match up
identically and see for the most part
we're looking here at a type of
chromosome X for the most part the child
and hd38 are the same however if you
zoom in here and look you can see that
there's a gap in the alignment here so
this is a chunk of sequence that appears
to be present in the Pro bands contig
that doesn't match up to the reference
assembly although if you can see just to
the right side of that there's a little
circle so at least a chunk of that
appears to to match to a downstream
segment of the reference which I'll show
you in a second so what this is telling
us here is that within cdkl5 within this
stretch of sequence we have a pro band
insertion
that appears to bear at least partial
similarity to a downstream stretch of
hd38 and so when you go through the work
to resolve what this sequence is uh it
turns out to be an L1 mediated insertion
that is somewhat complicated so L1 to
start with is a class of mobile element
that is still active in human genomes
and can still give rise to new mutations
and um in human beings so this is
mediated by an L1 jumping event so
essentially an L1 a mobile element
insertionist makes a copy of itself and
reinserts but as part of what this L1
did when it jumped is that it dragged so
you can see that in the blue this is the
seven kilobase insertion almost seven
kilobases part of it is matching an L1
perfectly so this is uh part the part
that tells you it's mediated by a brand
new L1 hop but what it also did is it
brought a segment from the downstream uh
Gene called ppf1 an intronic segment
from that Downstream Gene and combine
that two and a half KB of Downstream
segmental duplication combined with the
L1 lead to the seven kilobase insertion
but one important feature of L1 events
is that they leave what's called a
Target site duplication so where they
insert they actually make a second copy
of a short stretch of sequence and in
this case what I'm showing you at the
top here the target site duplication is
just over 100 nucleotides long but it
includes the entirety of cdk cdkl5 Exon
3 which is 35 base pairs long
and when you look inside the proband RNA
so that's it's a very faint band but you
can see it so here we're looking at an
RNA GL here of pro bands compared to Mom
and Dad and in that little white
asterisks is that uh is a is a band that
shifted up so that when you cut that out
in sequence we that is in fact rnas that
include two copies of uh cdkl5 so that's
cdk like
mrnas that include an extra copy of Exon
3 and because of 35 nucleotides long it
leads to a frameshift uh and this
essentially converts it to an expected
loss of function variance uh and lost
function alleles in this Gene are well
established as being associated with
this Developmental and epileptic
encephalopathy which matches up very
well with the the pro band's uh
phenotype and so we've considered this
likely path so effectively this is a
diagnostic variant for this family
so the next program I want to talk about
is is more a little more complicated but
the same basic picture here we're going
to be looking at
um contig comparison so we're looking at
Assemblies of in this case chromosome 7
or at least what we're calling derived
from those sevens for the Pro Band and a
derived chromosome 9. and you can see
here that we're looking at at the
chromosome 7 and chromosome 9 context in
the child and comparing that to seven
and nine and he 38 along the uh along
the top here the x-axis and what you can
see is that there's stretches of the
child's chromosome 7 that match to the
reference chromosome 7 but there's also
this interleave segments where you have
seven uh aligning to nine and in the
bottom here you also have child's Pro
chromosome 9 aligning to both ac38
chromosomide but also hd38 chromosome 7.
and so there's also this little spot
here in red which will show so basically
what we're looking at here is it looks
like evidence for translocations of
seven and nine into one another with
potentially you can see this little bit
where the diagonal is actually flipped
on its axis so it looks uh upside down
and we'll look at the next in this case
again we've faced all these so we know
that in this case the maternally
inherited chromosomes appear to be have
the normal structure the posternally
inherited chromosomes are the ones that
have this unusual translocation so you
can see we have this derived chromosome
7 which has a chunk of about three and a
half megabase of chromosome nine
inserted
uh and you see the reciprocal event here
where we have a derived nine that has a
large chunk of chromosome seven inserted
and this little red piece has turned out
to be a 240 kilobase inversion uh of
we're at one end of this translocation
you have this inversion and I look like
it out because it's it's just was it's
obviously part of the structure and
understanding what's happening here but
it also really threw us for a loop to
try to figure out this was a really
challenging region to ultimately
assemble but um it does illustrate the
power of where you can eventually get to
with this kind of data what was also
interesting about this Pro band is there
was a second series of rearrangements uh
in this case on chromosome six so again
I'm showing you derived chromosome 6 and
the Pro Band Here against reference in
this case it's all internal chromosome
six but one thing you'll notice is that
we have this very large uh inversion
here where a large segment of chromosome
6 is actually inverted relative to
reference but you also have this stretch
uh highlighted in this red circle here
where you have an extensive amount of
rearrangement and this is a we believe
this is result of chromothropsis where a
small region well small it's about
something like 10 megabases essentially
shatters and reassembles but it
reassembles and not necessarily in the
right order so to spare a lot of the
mechanics of how we had to drill through
that and and uh and Susan Heidi did a
lot of this just did an amazing amount
of work to reassemble that so what the
derived problem six here looks like is
we have this large inversion that
encompasses most of chromosome six
and then at one end here we have this 10
megabase segment where you have so here
we're showing you what the reference
chromosome looks like so a through H and
you can see we have this significantly
shuffled set of these are just different
segments that range from a 200 kilobases
to a megabase in size where you have a
completely different order and in some
cases the end of the pieces are inverted
relative to one another so really a sort
of radically altered structure within
this Locus
so to summarize here uh We've generated
long-read genome sequence and assemblies
from six trios with an unexplained
neurodevelopmental disorder uh the
assemblies were really remarkable
considering how it's essentially one
sequencing run uh and generation of data
so this isn't uh this is nearly HD 38
levels of contiguity obviously ac38 is
has a lot uh it's higher quality but
we're approaching that level uh size
rate of contiguity
and we can get those phased into
maternally and particularly inherited
segments and it's really remarkable to
think about doing this with essentially
a single sequencing kind of experiment
I didn't have time to talk about it
today but we looked we assessed variant
protection across a whole range of uh
variant types including SVS which I
showed you some examples but lots of
mobile element insertions low complexity
repeats uh we found uh an extensive
amount of fact of even protein altering
variants so smbs and indels in regions
that have low mappability of the
reference so these are areas where short
reads just can't align accurately but
long reads can get through it just fine
and you find variants that in fact could
be potentially impactful so essentially
you're getting a much larger or greater
fraction of the reference genome is
accessible via these long reads then
what you see from short reads
and really that for me the the exciting
uh part of this is that in fact two of
six programs that we looked at had
variants that we had completely missed
by previous testing including short read
genomes but that are in fact slightly
pathogenic and that lead directly to a
clinically relevant uh diagnosis so
obviously the numbers are too small to
say we're not saying that the the
ultimate success rate is going to be
one-third but it certainly uh it's
consistent with this being a pretty
substantial yield from long-break
genomes uh uh to previously unexplained
cases and of course
uh as we there's no evidence there's
basically nothing that long reads won't
see that short reads will so you get the
entire spectrum of normal normally
detected smbs and Intel but you also get
this additional fraction of variation
that is inaccessible so we're really
excited about this and I'm sure other
groups are as well that has cost decline
we've already seen over the past a
couple years that costs and efficiencies
of this process have really improved
dramatically and we certainly would
expect that to happen over the next
couple years as well that this should be
uh this will become a very powerful tool
both for clinical uh diagnosis and for
rare disease genetic uh research
Discovery and with that I would like to
thank uh in particular all the families
that have participated in research with
us and shared their their samples and
information and uh and work with us and
I'd like to point out um I've already
talked about Jane and Jeremy and Martina
and the other collaborators that we
had a pleasure to work with
uh Susan Hyatt James Lawler really were
leaders of
uh of doing this isn't it and I'm up
here talking but it's it's they've put
in a huge amount of work to figure out
all this these complicated uh structures
and it's um so it's Testament to their
uh their effort and uh and work in that
regard and with that I'll say thank you
and close